yo what is up everybody mad luigi here
and today i want to talk about something
i mentioned in my last video on the lore
of radon a good number of people in the
comments expressed contention with the
idea i presented that radon was acting
on ronnie's side so i want to spend a
little time looking solely at that and
presenting my theory in more detail i
think a closer examination will reveal
an even stronger case of an affable
relationship between the mightiest
demigod and his older sister
one of the main things i saw in many of
the comments that was used as evidence
of radon acting against ronnie was the
supposed fact that radon loved the
golden order which i think is
unsupported the idea goes that because
radon glorified his father to some
extent but really godfrey first elden
lord and the golden lion of the order
then radon also glorified the golden
order itself but this misses the point
of radon's affinity for godfrey verdan
is shown many times to take pride in
battle and war he liked the heroic
implications of the red hair he
inherited from his father and saw
himself as following in the footsteps of
godfrey in being the lord of the
battlefields lion
these idealizations show radon soying
out not over the order despite his
father and godfrey's strong connections
to it but to the glory of two god tier
warriors
radon seeks out and enjoys battle he has
never shown prioritizing something
related to the order over this theme and
if he is the one fighting morgot in the
opening slide then we have an example of
radon essentially going against the
order or what's left of it at least by
attacking the capital city this
connection may be tenuous as the golden
order was in shambles after the
shattering but at the least it certainly
does not lend credit to the idea that
radon was a big follower or fanatic of
the order
another piece of evidence against my
theory of team radon ronnie is the
description of the telescope which
states
during the age of the erd tree carrion
astrology withered on the vine the fate
once writ in the night skies had been
fettered by the golden order
this could be read as radon acting as an
agent of the order by holding back the
stars and halting any carrying fate but
i think that's a weak reading verdan
himself was part of the carrion line and
practiced space-based sorcery it is
unlikely that he would actively wither
away this tradition and source of power
yes he uses the gravity sorcery of the
alabaster lords and not the morkarian
glinstone magic but his love of battle
still makes me think that this is
unlikely plus taking both sentences of
the description together makes me think
this is a more broad point of lore
instead of being about radon holding
back the stars i'm inclined to read this
as the influence of the earth tree
pushing out the influence of anything
else such as the stars which the
carrions had studied and drawn power
from since before the earth tree's age
this seems to tie into the broader theme
of er tree supremacy by the order as
opposed to the single actions of one
demigod who isn't even a confirmed
follower of the order
and this video isn't just going to be me
on the back foot there's some more
context that didn't make it into my
radon video that i think supports the
idea of radon and ronnie having some
amicable understanding a lot of this
comes from the connection between their
second and commands blacksmith eg for
ronnie and witch hunter jaron for radon
eg is ronnie's war counsellor and used
to serve carrion royals
jaren used to be a wanderer before
spending time as a guest of the carrion
royals and then becoming radon's guest
commander
we see the carrion tie which makes sense
as both ronnie and radan would have
spent their youths in the carrying court
but further than this is their dialogue
both of them have words about the other
when asked jaren says well
i haven't heard that name in an age
then you must serve princess ronnie
the next time you speak to eg
tell him this
the festival of radon will surely set
rani's fate back into motion
bye-bye
is that old fool still hammering out
weapons
is enormous frame cramped in that little
place
bit of a haughty sword
strange fella when i knew him
and funny thing
his swords were all blunt as stone
but not one of them decayed when faced
with a scarlet rot
here we learned two important facts
first jaron is giving advice to eg about
how to help ronnie move forward by
killing radon in the festival
second is that despite jeering at them
jaren commends eg's weapons and reveals
that they were used by radon's army the
mention of scarlet rot references the
battle of radon and melania along with
their forces eg made some if not all of
the weapons that radon's army fought
melania with this is a large indication
of trust and allyship if anything was eg
was a core component of radon's armed
forces highlighting a link between
ronnie's side and radons and i think
this casts doubt on a notion i saw
people making in comments previously
that ronnie coordinated with melania to
attack radon why would she coordinate
and attack and then supply the other
side with arms yes ronnie could be a
giga chad manipulator making everybody
else fight each other and sowing chaos
but then we are really stretching to
make a conspiracy fit we don't have any
further direct or indirect evidence of
this kind of thing what we know for
certain is that ronnie aided radon in a
big way jaren is thankful for this aid
and wants to help ronnie his mentioning
of how to progress her fate indicates
some level of radon's holding back the
stars not having a huge goal of stopping
ronnie jaren is bound and wants to give
radon a good warrior's death and is
happy to help perrani at the same time
if rudon was holding back the stars to
get in ronnie's way then jaron likely
wouldn't be so forthcoming with
information which would aid ronnie here
he is clearly showing himself to be
somewhat at least on ronnie's side so a
natural follow-up would be that radon
was also on ronnie's side or at least
wasn't actively trying to mess with her
or her plans
so that's jaren's side if we head over
to eg we can hear him say jaren
now that's a name i haven't heard for a
while
before taking up the banner of general
radan
he was a guest of the karyan royal
family
an expert swordsman to be sure
but ever
eccentric
no surprise he'd get wrapped up in some
festival
oh no
wait
how did i not see it before
i ought to retire as war counsellor for
such a gross oversight
let me explain
the fate of the karyan royal family is
guided by the stars
as is the fate of lady rani
first air in the karyan royal line
but general radha is the conqueror of
the stars
who stood up to the swirling
constellations halting their movement in
a smashing victory
and so if general radan were defeated
the stars would once again resume their
movement
as would lady rani's destiny
perhaps
even revealing the elusive path
that leads to knock wrong
so eg rambles a bit more and doesn't
give as juicy of extra lore but his
words are still important because they
highlight how eg as war counselor
doesn't make any sort of insinuation
about radon acting against ronnie
through his star stopping he even goes
so far as to call it a smashing victory
which isn't necessarily positive but
basically sounds like eg is
congratulating radon for such an
impressive feat if it was clear that
radon was doing this to spite ronnie
then it doesn't seem likely that eg
would ignore that and go on to basically
commend radon
from these connections it gets pretty
hard to paint a picture of radon
intentionally acting against irani the
bond between their forces suggests that
they are on good terms or were their
most recent interaction radon's halting
of the stars seems like a grand feat
with at worst neutral implications in
how it impacts others at least by the
intention
perhaps no one knew what impact this
stellar battle would have but we can say
at least with a moderate amount of
certainty that it was not done with the
intention of spiting ronnie radon likely
just saw it as a grand avenue for battle
as there weren't too many big battles
left to be had after the time of
godfreak and because he did it when he
was young it would have been hard for
radon to then later on go get help from
eg when fighting melania if the star
conquest did intentionally mess with
eg's master's plan
now yes the eg weapon reference could be
explained in that eg made weapons for
radon's forces long ago and they just
happened to be rot resistant but the
strong theme of camaraderie and bond
between eg and jiren would imply that it
would be more reasonable to read the
situation as eg providing aid in that
more recent conflict the themes and
subtext and even explicit text really
point to eg and jiren being on good
terms and wanting to help each other and
to some degree each other's masters we
see that explicitly with jaren helping
ronnie
and such a positive bond between
sub-commanders while it could happen
with the main commanders budding heads i
don't see any reason to believe that
they're not representative of a positive
relationship between their commanders so
with all of that presented i think
ronnie and radon are very likely chill
with each other if not working together
in some degree so what do you think is
my lore theory convincing let me know in
the comments your thoughts on the matter
and any of these other pieces of lore
today i just wanted to delve a little
bit more into this so that will be it
for this video i hope you enjoyed and
make sure to subscribe if you want to
see more videos like this on eldon ring
lore game analysis and more thanks for
watching peace
also just one more example of vg and
jaren bean bros which supports ronnie
and radon being chill after we defeat
radon eg will say now the festival is
over
and general radhan is defeated
jeren's duties are finally fulfilled
though we served different masters
i could see he was truly adept in his
role
now the time has come to remind him of
an old promise made
with the stars of fate set into motion
a certain sorceress is dispossessed of
her immortality
finally
we can be rid of a long-standing carrion
weed
eg is talking about selen here who we
see jiren want to kill and who he can
help jiren kill or defend from jaren
regardless of where they stand with
selen this is another point of
connection between the two second in
commands jaron and eg seem to have quite
the number of ties between them and i
think this really makes the case that
their leaders ronnie and radon are on
pretty okay terms